what you want to do is return the  nutrients if you don't like clippings  people would remove them they would bag  it but you're losing nutrients when you  do that the leaving clippings is a good  thing for the mulching mower if you're  mulching leaves they can break your  beliefs down to kleiner bits they break  down a lot easier same with the grass  clippings the finer it is the quicker it  breaks down when it lays down in between  the grass better so you don't see it  making sure your mole when it's dry as  much as possible mowing the grass when  is dry makes it easier to disperse so  whether it has tree leaves in it or  grass leaves what you want to do is  return the nutrients we see generally  lawns that have had clippings remained  can go longer between fertilizer  applications so it's a way of reducing  your reliance on fertilizer